hello and welcome to this video this is
a new part of the e4 e5 black repertoire
series if you don't know what the series
is it's probably because it has been
neglected for a very long time but I'm
going to complete this series after all
let's see what we have in stock in this
installment it's about the Italian game
and in particular the Evans gambit so
we're going to do a couple of videos now
probably like three or four about the
Italian game with black I'm going to go
with Bishop c5 and we have to look at
various approaches here for what yeah
one of them is they haven't scampered
and this is going to be examined in this
particular video there will be more
videos about the Italian but I think it
makes sense to split them a little bit
so that every video on its own is
digestible and not too long okay
the Evans gambit very old opening yeah
developed or played first by captain
Evans someone from the nineteen
hundred's century really old stuff but
it was a an opening that was as as it
happened with so many forgotten opening
was kind of revitalized in the 1990s by
garry kasparov we used it to beat Vichy
are not amongst others nowadays the
Evans gambit is pretty much diffused and
this is due to the lines that I'm going
to show you and it's not that I'm it's
not that me didn't didn't make any
particular great discovery yeah I'm just
basically telling you what nowadays is
accepted as the main way to play with
black and I was really yeah getting
longed about that or I learned about
this approach look like when I saw
commentary for a recent game that
Fabiano Caruana one with black against
the top German GM and is the piano and
Caruana basically wrote you know the
Evans gambit that's totally harmless and
well I thought okay then he seems to
know its stuff let's just copy what
Khurana does and around him and his
approach I built that that overview here
in the video okay let's get going before
black takes that pawn and now c3 is
played with before white is giving away
that be pawn to gain that time that c3
move is supposed to come with a gain of
tempo by the way black can actually
declined again but with Bishop e6 and
this is surprisingly vital it's not
totally bad however I mean I think Black
has actually relatively decent
equalizing chances but it is just better
to change the pawn I mean we really have
to view it like that black rather should
take the pawn and see what happens in
many cases he can return the pawn for a
good position or I can really just keep
it so there's no reason not to take the
pawn so we will take it
c3 and now here's a parting of the ways
Bishop c5 a5 e 7 the main moves my
long-term favorite movie always was
Bishop e7 I had started with that move
when I when I began to play a 45 and
this is why I played it I never looked
at any other moles but now Bishop a5
seems to be them the best continuation
according to modern theory and we're
going to look at this move one point of
it is that compared to a Bishop c5 move
you're not running into this d4 with a
tempo so you don't have to react to d4
immediately okay Bishop a5 here that's
the first parting of the ways formed
white white now in in absolutely most
cases plays d4
yeah directly grab
that central space it has some logic
that would of course however white also
has tried to other moves and I mean a
couple couple of moves more I haven't
too sensible looking moves
this is castles and Queen b3 both
certainly do make some sense let's look
at both of them let's start with
canceling after castling and black has
some two choices he can play Knight f6
attacking in that pawn or play d6 the
difference is that after Knight f6 d4
it's slightly tricky now for black
because if you take you for now as this
is going to happen and then possibly
Bishop d5 or queen d5 this is in fact
this is interesting for black you can't
play that but the far more reliable move
is to start with d6 give that Center a
little bit of extra support um no deform
is what what is normally playing it's
difficult really to to suggest something
else I mean it looks it looks very very
logical that move
yeah and now what should black play
there are two alternatives you can play
like Laska did yeah back like about 100
years ago with Bishop to b6 that's very
solid continuation black is ready after
D takes d5 to play D takes d5 and after
Queen I'd play 98 simply giving that
pawn back and yeah being totally okay
here yeah this is a very simple
continuation that pretty much already
diffuses this whole approach for white
however black can also be more
enterprising and more testing I didn't
know and I know Bishop d6 that this was
the old Laska idea but when when I
started this year for them for the video
I also looked at Victor borgen's book
the polygons black
and what Oh God says yeah you know but
should be sixes are alright but Bishop
g4 is even stronger interesting that's a
very old move played by Steinitz back in
his birth Championship match in Havana
1892 against chigorin so we're dealing
about more than 120 years old
opening theory him it's always great
about chess I think it's a such a modern
game full of technology but you have
those really good games that sometimes
are really still relevant
yeah Bishop g4 that put some pressure on
the center yeah black is developing
rapidly first thing to check is that
this is no track at all working because
of this an idea Queen b3 check and black
can reach it dance well yeah what is
this now like two two pieces up that's a
disaster so this is not possible yeah
why I cannot take one of seven he can
try some some other moves
um Bishop b5 is one of them trying to
play d5 but it's not so dangerous like
antique and just develop the reason is
that black is ready after d5 to play a
six Bishop a4 and b5 and this looks
entirely harmless you know like this get
if white now takes on a form black will
take on f3 and now go back to b6 I'd
have a good position yeah this weekend
pawn structure is a problem for white
one thing that needs to be mentioned is
in this particular line that instead of
ten to five white can also think about
the booth Queen eight form that's
interesting and threatens Queen takes a
five black can take on f3
she takes and now it's important to play
the move Bishop to b6 after d5 you've
got a six a counter-attack and now
Bishop d3 is answered by passivity for
now the nice tactical sequence and
useful to know because this is kind of
unusual and it's better to have seen
that idea before and instead of hoping
to find it over the board this is very
important to understand when you watch
such a theoretical overview like the one
I'm presenting it is not absolutely
necessary and sometimes really difficult
to do to learn all those moves by heart
but the thing is if you have seen it
before the likelihood that you will find
it in an actual game over the board is
much much higher in my games melon over
the board games I quite often tend to
not exactly know what what is the super
precise way to do it but the likelihood
that I find a good move is much higher
if I had seen it before sometimes I just
remember it or sometimes I feel like
isn't this like this kind of setup
that's right and then you could if you
find it yeah this is why it makes sense
to have looked at it beforehand what
other moves are there Queen B 3 this is
a bit more dangerous and f7 is under
pressure now the point is black is
ignoring that he can take him checked
yeah now after G takes
black is going to should be six it's
important yes this is under heavy
pressure very difficult to hold and we
shouldn't forget that black with Queen
age for possibly Knight f6 can get a
rather quick attack and we are not
material down yes black yeah this is an
equal material position where black has
really really nice counter chance on the
kingside now it is sharp obviously but
absolutely not bad for black at all very
interesting variation um white can also
instead of from capturing on a3 can
insert that capture and then take in
this case black can you grab that pawn
on d4 note that black is better
developed here that's important to him
white may hope that this King is
somewhat shaky but where are the pieces
to attack it that's that's very
important to understand blacks
development is quicker here there is
also the move Queen April this is what
she Goran actually played in one of the
games against Steinitz and we follow
that game with ETA XT for like it's
really just grabbing that and now I'm
Knight takes d4 Knight g7 is relatively
harmless Bishop g5 yeah setting up a
couple of pins can be answered by Queen
d7 and Bishop e7 90-84 is totally fine
and it is a bit it is a bit sharp but
there's really no a huge issue that
black has to fear and here we can cast a
long actually does it happen that often
in the slides but now it's possible
and black has a fine position here white
has spent lots of time moving the Queen
around and black is just much better
much better mobilized that's important
to understand yeah we very often want to
return some material for speeding up our
development that's modern the modern way
to handle play against cameras you have
to be very flexible in some cases you
just take the material and say okay I'm
defending yeah and I'm optimistic and a
sea lion said that are really showing me
that that I have a defendable position
but you should do that all the time if
you have a good opportunity to return
material you should do you should do
just that this is a huge difference to
the approach that say in the 19th
century when people felt kind of obliged
yeah like like a question of Honor yet
to just take the material and this is
nowadays of course rather naive we just
want to play the best possible moves
yeah here black can can take them and go
a6 intending to go b5 yeah Bishop d5 no
g7 jazz ticks do you find b5 Queen 83
yeah this was the mentioned game between
chigorin and Steinitz and here Stein
it's made a mistake he played night to
be for which there wasn't entirely clear
actually
but night to d4 instead of night before
oops wrong one an ID for instead of
night before is as astronomers and in
fact here after Queen takes and five
which is yeah basically the only
critical thing there is Queen f6 and
this is the problem Knight f3 is
threatened 92 and the rook is hanging
and the
Queen a3 this before and black as some
already firmly though this is in good
shape yeah we can we can check him
various lines queen bee to black and
take him check until you can actually go
for funny mating a check this is a
really cute line given by but below gun
yeah this is this is a TechEd
and if white tries to snatch this here
we're going to play j5b uptick slew
create and then so this will end in a
checkmate ultimately I mean White's
what's a king on h4 is just a complete
joke so Queen B - it's not even working
Queen a4 check is a bit tougher king of
892 check check and like we'll wrap the
rook here in the corner and has a pretty
substantial advantage let's sum sum that
up we're already relatively deep into
that line yeah this is our starting
position there and g4 is the maintenance
and in case of castles this is what we
just checked we go with d6 d4 and now we
have a choice Bishop d6 cons
conservative and safe or Bishop g4 which
is a bit sharper but probably really
good for us so that's a nice choice to
have white also has tried in one move
six the move Queen b3 directly attacking
on f7 the best reply is Queen to e7 we
are covering that with the Queen and now
de force the only move that is some kind
of test to black
if wise choice Bishop III and we go d6
what else
let's castles Knight f6 deform and
castles it's important to understand
black is building up this central
defensive formation and if white doesn't
get something going rather quickly then
like is just a pawn up for nothing and
this is exactly the case here
black is just a part of and don't
underestimate the the importance of the
missing people and that the b-pawn is
not on the board
this have also some structural
significance for example here black also
has some pressure on the center in this
situation you know Knight takes e4 is a
very real possibility and if white feels
inclined to close the center right then
here the missing be pawn is very
important because you get this fantastic
c5 square which is totally unopposed you
can go ignite here this should be 65 or
95 this is also from a structural point
of view a really bad position far better
than Bishop e3 here is some in fact and
approach d4 b black is still in very
good shape but it is better than Bishop
e3 because this is much more aggressive
and black should respond with Knight f6
that's an important point if you go d6
here after d5 you put yourself into some
difficulties I mean 94 is not totally
totally bad but it is far more tricky
than you then you wanted to be not f6 is
better and please don't take and this
after castles can be very very riskier
don't give up the center then what idea
is to in the counter check on your form
or just solidify with d6 here Knight f6
is a good cut
the reason is that D takes e5 which
looks kind of dangerous at first isn't
that dangerous this is the main move and
we will look look at this a little bit
later if white goes d5 let's start with
that white goes d5 then black has a very
strong reply that is also useful to know
we can jump into d4 black is not
retreating to be aid or something like
that 94 that's a very very nice resource
black takes in point eggs it's just far
more active and now black is rather
active castles castles and their three
that has been played in a game and he
takes Knight eggs
I'm sorry Bishop e3 first d6 93 and 95
King she won't f5
he takes half that has been played in a
game between Boris Savchenko and
victorious militant and ultimately to
played rook takes f5 but Bishop takes a5
is much stronger and almost leading to
yeah to win for black and it's just it
just says as bad I mean black is very
much ready to start something like Queen
age 493 Bishop b6 attacking with all his
pieces when White's pieces are rather
ridiculous here on the Queen side they
just look at pawns for with no
particular purpose the real issue is why
Bishop f5 was not chosen by smell it is
that she didn't find the right reply to
g4 g for looks I mean it's the most
obvious move ever him that that you have
to check it but blacks reply it is far
from obvious it's something that if you
give it to a computer it will
immediately spit out the reply and then
you check it and you recognize oh wow
that's immensely strong but seeing that
in an actual game is something
the key is b5 it's a really funny move
and what is pride supposed to do
if he takes with the knight then Bishop
g-force is strong it's a very weird
motif takes this all son Queen e4 and
this is actually going to end in major
yeah something like that
it's a total disaster so the knight is
driven away from that control over the
you Foursquare if the bishop takes black
plays a6 uh-huh
what's the point well if you retreat
then rook b8 and well may I said Queen
going yeah it still has to also observe
the night here white is just losing
material big material so Queen takes
them that's very simple and this was a
great opportunity for us mini to win the
game basically after Bishop f5 if g4 is
not working the next move will be Queen
h4 and wine is just completely going
downhill it's a bit of a deep line in
terms of number of moves but it is a
very plausible line after the 594 there
is not really much that white can do and
in fact it seems that why this is
clearly in bad shape here d5 is just not
a good move Bishop a3 has been tried
after which we go d6 now d5 is again
answered by a 94 this is an important
moment to remember because after Knight
takes it takes you can be very very
irritated by this young opportunity and
in fact early it is a it is a peace
sacrifice Bishop d7 and Queen takes
platform King D 1 yeah King F 1 is
losing straight away due to that one
note that white screen is completely off
and there is really no way to to send
simply defend against blacks attack we
were just reading this and made next
move and white only has this ready to
continue and this is a disaster
so King D 1 and now black just castles
and place the piece down but with a
fantastic attack this is hanging the
King is completely insecure and white
has absolutely no coordination it's a
disaster I mean it's not just an attack
if you give it to an engine it says
black flat-out wins here you could come
you could continue to analyze this to a
flat-out win because it is there but
it's also just possible to play it over
the border attack is just so strong so
g5 is not really doing much what else d
takes d5 that is much a little bit more
testing however after 95 9525 which are
here king e7 we get a position that is
very very similar or can even transpose
to what happened
in the in the relatively mainline yet if
Y takes only 5 or move 8 yeah
let's look at this let's look at this
and then you see that it's it's
essentially the same thing I'm talking
about this capture 90s Knight takes
Queen takes King yourself that's a very
comparable position that's only Bishop
83 and d6 inserted which for example
white could do now yeah it's um it's
possible but not helping him at all by
the way because the bishop is just
biding on that d6 pawn without any
particular purpose this game or this
position was actually reached in games
and one game was between two strong
players between Bhardwaj abhava and live
on aronia and this happened in the game
here with Aronian being black rook F
and now dubov up Layton
Bishop ut5 after which there should be
six and then later 94 was essentially
killing one yeah black is already far
far better here he's got a strong
quinium and the king only seven is
surprisingly safe really surprisingly
safe black handsome has an excellent
position really and it's a bit better
maybe to um consider on this 12 here
f4 it's a bit better but black is still
in good shape we can really take that
pawn don't be afraid them bishops you
form and then just King d8 the king of
safe hand with Bishop e6 check actually
black also has some counter counter
threats it's not just that we are
passive or so and for us all so we can
White's King quite a bit so we have
really good counter chances here this
was the move six Queen b3 the important
thing to remember is we go Queenie 7 and
after deform we're not going T 6 but we
do this counter attack if black is given
time to play d6 and castles he just will
be a pawn up for nothing
so what essentially has to do something
quick and we saw that this quick action
just not leading to that much because
black will gain time to move f8 and
quite often with Bishop e6 94 get some
serious counter play against White's
King so this is the move 6 parting of
the ways there is let's go back there is
this castles that we looked at earlier
Queen b3 answered by Queen e7 and the
main move deform this system means that
white is some setting his hopes upon for
a couple of years but it also doesn't
seem to be that threat
the move I'm going to recommend is the
six as Kara wanna plate however it is
worth mentioning that in that already
mentioned book by Victor Borge on the
black weapons blue gun actually goes a
different way he goes with b5 I
completely forgot to move which is
surprisingly strong it looks rather
strange and to just ditch that pawn but
it's possible to play it and white is
probably taking I don't want to look at
this in detail just want to mention this
possibility because it is a rather it's
an offbeat line that requires to
learning whatsoever and is still pretty
decent white will take black takes him
yeah the reason for the b5 movies if
black would take here then 95 refutes
that thanks Hanks yeah and this is Jeff
not a good position
yeah Bishop e6 and stronger actually
yeah because the King has to take check
and then you get it back b5 that p5 move
is basically just trying to dislodge
that bishop from that diagonal 94 takes
takes Queen takes Queen f6 and Black has
excellent equalizing chances it's an
interesting line that b5 move but in
comparison still I would prefer what
Cara wanna ditch d6 I still want to
mention that this is a decent decent
idea that is somewhat unexplored so d6
um what does white try here normally and
he normally goes with Queen b3 and we
will look at this in the main this is
the main continuation we checked later
what what else is there D takes d5 has
been played not just take here and again
black is taking with the pawn to be
ready after Queen the Asian 9895
play this position we have returned the
pawn but we have a very healthy pawn
structure as black yeah the pawns are
all back on the seventh rank which is
the best possible structure in terms of
avoiding weaknesses
while White has two weakest ones I mean
it's not the end of the world why does
not need to lose this necessarily or
anything but like it's totally
comfortable that D takes d5 doesn't look
too threatening if white takes then
Queen b3 this is a bit more interesting
and the Queen trade but after Queen f6
and it also seems to be questionable if
this is enough Black is going for Knight
g7 and castles and he doesn't get
anywhere really really quickly for
example we can briefly look at a game
between when master r2 a cool girl with
white and Vishy Anand that was played
with castles Bishop d6 Bishop g5 queen
g6 Bishop d5 and now f6 very strong move
by not attacking this and later
intending for not g7 that was a rapid
game by the way um f6 Bishop g8 f g5 and
are not already had the better position
with the bishop and it's nothing really
happening to the king
yeah Knight g5 was was what Coogan had
attended but it turns out that after
King f8 very cold blooded reply 96 check
King takes g8 black is in fact winning
yeah after the king of aid Knight takes
Bishop h3 we are already dealing with
the totally forced win on g3 Queen here
check
and there's this made threat and the f1
cannot move because of that strong
bishop yeah a very quick winter for
black for the former world champion
means that D takes d5 is harmless
if white castle's we transpose to six
castles d6 d4 that was the situation
where Bishop e6 was the Alaska line and
Bishop g4 were steinitz more ambitious
line both were fine Bishop g4 is just
more interesting so it all boils down to
Queen B 3 attacking that f7 pawn and
here again Queen e7 it's not entirely
satisfactory so we go to descent not the
most natural move ever but it is simply
what has to be done due to the specifics
of the position one very important ideas
that whenever white takes on your faith
which is the main line I'm going to show
you the idea and then show the
alternative lines Bishop d6 is the key
reply that introduces this Knight a5
idea that is happening in many sub
variations here also the ones that are
not that great for what
quite often Blackwell after d5 played
Bishop e6 introduced that night a5 yeah
four count on those two pieces not
winning one of them but yeah provoking a
reply
yeah DD takes d5 is the main move what
else is there White has also tried to
Castle here Bishop d6 is good yeah
intending Knight a5 and improving that
bishop position if white takes now on e5
the Knight e5 is really completely fine
for us yeah Queen goes up and we take
him here
six and we've got a position again where
black has a healthy pawn structure and
here even to bishops it's an entirely
unsatisfactory for white white can try
to keep the tension but here 95 is of
course the idea Queen c2 gigs gigs and
now quits his six strong looking at that
night yeah and where's white going it it
probably has to change one be six I mean
if he keeps things on the board it
really doesn't look like there's any
compensation at all so he has to take
him take him and probably take that form
back after which we go Queen a4
interesting little idea possible due to
the opened half open a file again we
have a good structure this is somewhat
wrong of course with the opposite color
fishes but what has absolutely no hopes
of an of any advantage here so let's go
back again yeah there are a couple of
lines but don't be afraid if you know
them the the main ideas it will be very
very likely that you can find stuff over
the board Bishop b5 also has been tried
for that pin but it doesn't seem very
dangerous this 86 and on Bishop a4 we go
Bishop e7 introducing the b5 idea which
would trap that Bishop actually yeah and
now something like Bishop takes Queen
cakes dxdx takes
oops and again Queen e6 is something we
saw in an earlier line of almost black
it's totally fine now it's got the
bishop pair and the better structure
instead of cancelling on for eight White
has also tried not be too yeah so a
couple of alternatives there for white
but none of them
really need too much again this should
be six is a key move a for having this
tactical idea times and Knight f6 the
Anna's position has been reached a
couple of times three or four games but
it seems to be totally fine things that
have petroleum are a five for example
very aggressive ninety-five a5 Bishop a5
D takes and ninety four are the ideas
that here f7 is collapsing
but 94 is okay and I think black can be
confident here after he takes we Castle
we have secured our king and black as an
exchanger I mean why it is fairly active
here with with Queen and Bishop but it
doesn't it doesn't seem to be entirely
enough D takes e5 was played in a recent
game in the German league between
international master seller and
Grandmaster Polly grass from from
Romania and I think I'm not mistaken
yeah that was an entirely unsuccessful
idea now f2 was hanging +95 yet sailor
took him and after Bishop actually king
into and Bishop c5 d takes and castles
blacks position was almost winning with
good play yeah it's equal material and
as this King is a complete joke
well white structures also completely
demolished so and that's not working at
all we have to return all the way to
this position
it really is d takes d5 if there's
something it probably is with with this
this month something for white and again
Bishop e6 we don't recapture yeah if we
recapture here white always has castles
rook e1 Bishop e3 those kind of idea
and it's much better to play here and
introduce that 95 idea in fact this is
very difficult to prevent yeah and a key
idea for black to get rid of the good
bishop on c4 yeah white has tried a
number of moves now the latest news that
has been tried also in that mentioned
game is a piano kawana is a four I look
at that last what has been trying not be
t2 that's the most frequent move that
has been played there but black here has
a good position he's got a choice
between two attractive continuations one
that is very very solid and one that is
a bit sharper more ambitious 95 is a
solid one Queen c2 takes takes d5 and
black is totally fine yeah Jake's takes
96 I'm sorry
check for us that's a bad check there
should be seven cakes takes like this
this and black is fine yeah we have
opposite colored bishops eco material
and this bishop will be strong one c6 I
mean black can easily even play that on
four for more than just a dead draw or
something but in comparison the other
line is a bit more exciting and let's go
back the other line is with where is it
yeah that is actually to take on your
five with the pawn and yeah more
exciting also a little bit a little bit
more risky it will probably go like this
Bishop a 395 and Queen before
threatening a little made them and this
yeah black is a pawn up White has a
little bit of compensation with the
development but it's questionable of it
is enough never forget that this is
terrible PCM and it's not a clear simple
attack if Black gets 9006 and castles
and he seems fairly safe so I think this
can be recommend and take that pawn and
play form or the other continuation or
however was also very solid and White
has also tried to Bishop b5 but after a
six lose you pay for a 97 there is not
that it's not clear what white is gained
I mean this looks rather weird Bishop
there with the Queen iam if white cheeks
and queen takes me we have this and
castles it looks very very healthy for
black II takes and also aspect right but
95 again is it's a reply and here only
black can be better if anybody it's got
the bishop pair better structure we know
the deal what else cancelling has been
played but this is a position we had
seen before by a different move or it's
always the same story we return the pawn
of a queen trade here even and we will
get the Queen trade I guess with a good
structure with two bishops and so how
good can it get yeah it's really really
nice so what about this a form is that
really doing what a huge favor yeah it
seems playable but it is not
particularly great again of course black
is going 95 Queen a - that was one
purpose of the a form to allow that
covering a queen a to change takes 97
note that black is not behind in
development by allowing y to capture
this pawn we have returned this point
but we have two bishops we have good
development and we have no clear
weaknesses so that's an ideal position
ready here Nyssa piano in that recent
game
played the move Bishop III after which
black already could have gotten a very
distinct advantage so this is not an
improvement at all over Nakamura are not
in that game Nakamura grabbed on d6 this
is stronger C takes castles castles this
is how it went
Queen D 396 anthem black had no problems
whatsoever
LSN it's it's good healthy complete
development to bishops and structurally
I mean here after this capture on d6 and
like retaking with the C pawn structure
is probably about evenly matched in
terms of weaknesses but again you have
two bishops and really not not much to
fear that Bishop 83 minutes then I
mentioned that was played by his piano
is really better it's really worse I'm
sorry Bishop III why is that why is that
worse I mean castling as Kawana did
already led to a nice position but the
most d5 is even stronger it directly
clarifies the situation in the center
and probably there's nothing better for
what to take and this now Quinn takes
and blacks position is really excellent
might takes place c4 I'm trying to play
c5 we have 9 f4 and this is still a
square whele but it's not going to trap
our our Bishop yeah Bishop e3 that was
really not a good invention there by
vanessa piano after d5 blankets just
better the queen retreats we have 96 for
example as a good move or we can just
take them and again after Queen takes
Queen d5 Black has a very nice position
where you can only argue
about how advantageous it is so this is
the Evans gambit as it stands nowadays
black has to act in a flexible way
sometimes giving back the pawn for boot
structure sometimes for the bishop pair
we are not just grabbing material and
and and trying to suffer them yeah but
flexibility is the key there are also
other lines that feel very romantic less
than in nature like what we looked at
here and castles d6 d4 Bishop g4 Queen
b3 where white was allowed to take and
so that is a really romantic his style
opening line on it all the Evans gambit
has lost lots of his bite by this
precise by employing this precise
defense from the black player it's still
very much important to have something
ready so I think this is a useful video
that when you really get it on the get
it over the board that you will be able
to find the right continuation there or
in some cases simply remember what's
right I think black has little to fear
with Bishop a5 on move 5 here he's
playing an ambitious continuation way
even if you've ever even have chances to
be better
why does playing something or something
weird and it's still fairly solid we're
not risking anything much so Bishop a5
is a is a good continuation and also I
think a more interesting than Bishop e7
what I usually play now I think I would
go for Bishop a5 and see what happens
you know of course in blitz chess it's a
bit tricky with those more forcing lines
you have to be very um technically alert
there if you play and there's somewhat
sharper metal and manner but should be 7
is a little bit easier
that regard okay I hope you enjoyed this
video about the diffuse of the Evans
gambit and the series will continue with
the other Italian game sub lines yeah
see 3d 3d for there are a couple of
lines and step-by-step we'll go through
them yeah
thanks for watching